is this focused
i just want to make a video real quick
just want to be kind
in this morning i'm just warning
everybody who's spewing negativity and
trying to tear down others in their own
insecurity i'm coming for you all this
[ __ ] energy that i've been getting
from all these friends you've got a
problem now i'm a [ __ ] 5.0 version of
myself now i'm a different [ __ ] dude
after all this stuff you have to
understand you're in deep [ __ ]
trouble i'm coming for you i'm
suffocating you i've been putting
pressure on you that's why you're
nervous that's why you've gotten louder
but i'm being really [ __ ] nice right
now when i tell you i'm [ __ ] coming
for you and i'm bringing practical
optimism down your [ __ ] throat and
slowly but surely i'm gonna hunt down
all the [ __ ] negativity in this
[ __ ] universe and i'm gonna [ __ ]
choke you the [ __ ] out i'm being nice
right now because i'm calmly and i mean
calmly giving you a [ __ ] walk but
after this energy that's come into my
[ __ ] soul this weekend from all these
[ __ ] people i'm gonna [ __ ] come
and get you i'm gonna [ __ ] come and
get you person by person person by
person word by word word by word and i'm
gonna [ __ ] find you and i'm gonna
smoke you out i'm not coming with hate
for you i'm not countering your [ __ ]
hate chess moves with [ __ ] hate chess
moves i'm coming with straight love and
compassion the wrong [ __ ] dude with
the wrong [ __ ] skills
got instilled the right [ __ ] [ __ ] and
he's coming for all the [ __ ]
negativity in the world piece by piece
strategy by strategy decision by
decision execution by execution i'm
gonna [ __ ] get you i see you hiding
in the corners of twitter and discord
every one of you and your cynicism and
your negativity is in deeper trouble
than ever before because i'm more
motivated than ever i'm more focused
than ever i'm stronger than ever and i'm
gonna [ __ ] get you you understand
signed scary [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
one two three big for glyphs this is the
five this is the vibe i love you guys